DEMOCRATIC PARTY WAS THE
PARTY OF FDR SAW ITSELF AS
THE CHAMPION OF THE WORKS
CLASS IN SOME WAYS IT WAS.
TODAY'S DEMOCRATS FEEL
CONSTITUENCY.
THE TOP PARTY OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY APPEARS TO
BE MASS IMMIGRATION
DISPLACEMENT OF WORKERS
HERE.
MANY IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
ORDERED FOR SHUT DOWN OF THE
GOVERNMENT IN PURSUIT OF
FULL DACA AMNESTY.
HOUSE LEADER NANCY PELOSI
PARENTS DID A GREAT THING BY
BREAKING OUR IMMIGRATION
LAWS.
MARTIN O'MALLEY WAS THE
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR OF
MARYLAND.
HE WILL BE ONE OF THE PEOPLE
CHARTING THE FUTURE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
GOVERNOR, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
MERRY CHRISTMAS.
>> Tucker: MERRY CHRISTMAS.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE
ELECTION OF TRUMP OPENS UP A
BUNCH OF QUESTIONS FOR
DEMOCRATS, OBVIOUS ONE WHO
PARTY OF THE MIDDLE CLASS OR
NOT.
THAT.
BUT THAT'S NOT OBVIOUS FROM
THE PRIORITIES.
WOULD WOULD THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY PUT AMNESTY FOR DACA
RECIPIENTS AT THE VERY TOP
OF THE POLICE OF THINGS TO
GET DONE AT THE END OF THE
YEAR.
>> LOOK, I THINK THE CORE OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY REMAINS
THAT COMMITMENT TO THAT
TIMELESS AMERICAN IDEAL OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL.
AND WERE WE NOT A COUNTRY OF
IMMIGRANTS WE WOULD NOT BE
THE COUNTRY OF CREATIVITY,
INNOVATION, DIVERSITY, WHICH
PARTY BELIEVES IN THE
DIGNITY OF EVERY PERSON AND
DIGNITY OF WORK.
AND CONTRARY TO SOME FALSE
ASSERTIONS, THERE IS NOT A
ZERO.
MEANING THAT AS MANY PEOPLE
LEFT.
>> Tucker: NO, NO.
THERE HAS BEEN MASS
IMMIGRATION FOR 52 YEARS AND
HAS COMPLETELY CHANGED THE
DEMOGRAPHIC MIX OF THE
COUNTRY AND POPULATION OF
THE COUNTRY.
WE HAVE MORE THAN A MILLION
COMING LEGALLY.
>> THERE HAS ALWAYS BEEN
LEVELS.
WE HAVE NEVER HAD LEVELS
THIS HIGH IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
THAT'S A FACTS.
I'M NOT ARGUING AGAINST
IMMIGRATION.
I'M JUST.
>> Tucker: WE HAVE A HIGHER
PROPORTION NOW.
WAGES WHICH ARE STAG SNANT
AND THAT SEEMS LIKE OBVIOUS
ISSUE FOR DEMOCRATS AND
SOMETHING TO BE UPSET ABOUT.
IMPORTING A MILLION LOW WAGE
WORKERS EVERY YEAR DOES NOT
MAKE WAGES GO UP.
IT'S A MATH QUESTION IT
DOESN'T WORK.
WHY WOULD THEY BE FOR THAT?
>> YEAH, HERE IS THE RUB
THOUGH, TUCKER.
IT'S -- YOU HAVE PEOPLE IN
OUR COUNTRY ALREADY.
AND THESE DREAM ACT KIDS,
KIDS COVERED BY DACA.
THEY WERE BROUGHT HERE AT A
WANTED TO COME OR DIDN'T
WANT TO COME.
THE ONLY PLACE COME IS THE
UNITED STATES.
WHAT'S A REAL DRAG ON WAGES
IS WHEN YOU FORCE PEOPLE TO
BOOKS.
TO BE EXPLOITED BECAUSE THEY
CANNOT GO TO ENFORCE
CONTRACTS AND THEY CANNOT
AND THEY ARE SUSCEPTIBLE TO
BEING TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF.
THESE ARE THE THINGS THAT
HOLD DOWN WAGES.
WHEN WORKERS FULL LIGHT OPEN
SOCIETY THAT'S BETTER FOR
ALL OF US.
>> Tucker: BRINGING AMNESTY
TO PEOPLE.
WAGE IS A THIRD OF WHAT IT
IS HERE.
WHY HASN'T THAT HAPPENED YET
IF THAT WORKS?
>> WHAT I'M SAYING IS THIS.
THAT THESE KIDS ARE ALREADY
HERE.
THE ONLY COUNTRY THEY KNOW
IS THE UNITED STATES.
>> Tucker: I GET IT, LOOK,
IT'S A TOUGH SITUATION FOR
THEM.
CUTS OR THE OPIOID CRISIS OR
THINGS THAT ACTUALLY AFFECT
MIDDLE CLASS AMERICA.
WHY IS THE ONE ISSUE THEY
HERE ILLEGALLY.
SAYING.
BUT I THINK YOU ASCRIBE TO
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, YOU
KNOW, MYOPIC WORLD VIEW.
THESE KIDS ARE IMPORTANT.
EVERY DAY IS ALSO IMPORTANT.
BUT, MOST -- WE ALSO, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WAS
FIGHTING AGAINST THIS 1.3
TRILLION-DOLLAR TAX CUT THAT
PRIMARILY BENEFITS THE
WEALTHY THAT ISN'T NEEDED.
THAT ISN'T FISCALLY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
ADVOCATING IN STATES AND
SO, YES, PART OF THAT IS
THAT WE CARE ABOUT THESE
KIDS.
THESE KIDS WHOSE ONLY
COUNTRY IS THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
GOVERNOR, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
AND MERRY CHRISTMAS.
WHAT DO YOU IF HE CAME TO